un paso fugas por el número 10 de Downey
Street con solo unas pocas semanas en el
cargo fueron varias las crisis por
sortear el pasado 6 de septiembre
listros asumió con la esperanza de darle
un giro económico a Reino Unido
Confío en que juntos podemos capear la
tormenta podemos reconstruir nuestra
economía y podemos convertirnos en el
país moderno y brillante que sé que
podemos ser
sólo dos días después una noticia que le
daba la vuelta al mundo
la muerte de Su Majestad la reina es un
gran impacto para la nación y el mundo
la Reina Isabel II fue la roca sobre la
que se construyó la Gran Bretaña moderna
tras el Duelo trozo se enfocó nuevamente
en su principal objetivo la crisis
económica a final de septiembre y de la
mano de suministro de finanzas cuasi
cuarten La Premier dio a conocer un
polémico plan económico que hizo que la
libra esterlina se desplomara a niveles
nunca vistos el punto más controvertido
tenía que ver con un nuevo impuesto para
los más ricos una medida que dividió al
partido conservador y genera una crisis
de gobierno al interior de los Story
pese a las críticas La Premier continuó
defendiendo su plan y días después
modificó parte del proyecto incluyendo
el polémico punto de impuestos para los
que más ganan
sé que el plan presentado hace solo 10
días ha causado un poco de turbulencia
lo entiendo no entiendo estamos
escuchando y hemos escuchado
el 14 de octubre la crisis se agudiza
todos decide sacrificar a suministro de
finanzas y pide su dimisión
hable con él y temprano sentí muchísimo
perderlo es un gran amigo y Comparte mi
visión de poner a este país en el camino
del crecimiento
hoy le he pedido ayer en mihan que se
convierte en el nuevo ministro
la riendas económicas del país pasaron a
manos del experimentado Jeremy home
quien llegó Pisando fuerte y en Solo dos
días destrozó el plan financiero que
había sido la bandera política de Trust
en primer lugar revertiremos casi todas
las medidas Fiscales anunciadas en el
plan de crecimiento Hace tres semanas
que no han comenzado Las legislación
parlamentaria
ahora el barco de Downey Street Busco un
nuevo Capitán que lo lleve a buen Puerto
en momentos difíciles